if you've been wondering where two of
the most famous sisters in the world
have been since they stopped making
movies together
you're probably not alone here's why you
don't hear very much about the olsen
twins anymore
if you grew up watching full house
you're definitely familiar with the
olsen twins first big role but you might
not realize just how young they were
when they got started
after both mary kate and ashley were
cast to play the family's most adorable
member michelle at just
six months old they became stars thanks
to the show's enduring popularity and
overwhelming affection for the character
i've been on full house
for ever
however since the twins started so young
they didn't really get to choose their
careers
full house was a great opportunity for
mary kate and ashley but it makes sense
that they eventually retired in favor of
other pursuits
whether or not mary kate and ashley got
the chance to choose their childhood
profession
there's no denying that their tenure as
actresses was insanely lucrative
my favorite thing is eating a cake after
they got older mary kate and ashley
launched dual star entertainment
spawning a fan club that served as a
subscription site and as the backbone to
the twins growing media empire
in 2007 the olsens even joined
powerhouses like talk show host oprah
winfrey on the forbes ranking of the
wealthiest women in entertainment with
the publication estimating their net
worth at 100 million dollars and noting
that dual star sold quote 1 billion
dollars worth of merchandise worldwide
in a year
everything from videos to hair care
products at the time the twins were just
20 years old
making their fortune at a seriously
young age enabled them to step out of
the limelight fairly early
it might seem a little crazy that mary
kate and ashley were raking in literal
billions before they could legally drink
but when you consider just how hard the
twins worked throughout their acting
career you'll understand why
after full house the two embarked on a
series of features television films and
direct-to-video releases throughout the
1990s
all told the twins appeared in 27
projects between 1992
and 2004 however 2004 brought an end to
their joint acting careers with new york
minute
their second theatrical release
ultimately the film performed poorly
both critically and commercially
having one of the lowest openings of all
time which wasn't exactly a favorable
conclusion to the girl's acting career
the olsens were two of the most famous
young women in the world throughout
their childhood
and adolescence however it should come
as no surprise that this fame came with
some
serious drawbacks specifically some very
gross objectification
in june of 2019 writer yomi adegoke
penned a piece about men in dark corners
of the internet who quote
count down until young women turn 18 and
become legal
mentioning the olsen twins as an example
mary kade and ashley had grown up on
camera
from their casting and full house at
just six months old onward
a dagokay road men patiently waiting
until they hit puberty and their
fantasies made the switch from perverse
to pedestrian made me feel queasy
a dagokay spends the rest of her essay
detailing the seriously damaging
implications of this upsetting trend
which was potentially harmful to the
olsens and may have played a role in
their decision to leave
acting in the years since new york
minute flopped at the box office the
olsens have found solace and success in
an entirely new venture in the world of
high fashion
in 2006 the twins launched the row the
brand was the result of ashley's goal to
create the perfect white t-shirt
however the two preferred to let the
clothes speak for themselves and didn't
even do a public interview about the row
for several years after its debut
it's not a trend based brand
it's really about what these women want
to be wearing
every day the row which the olsens still
own and manage alongside lions like
elizabeth and james
a concept named for their siblings has
won several awards
it even took home the highest honor of
the council of the fashion designers of
america
the women's wear designer of the year
award two years in a row
in 2018 the olsons announced that the
row would launch a menswear line
complete with knits suits and denim
why return to acting when you've got a
successful fashion collection
in the absence of their acting career
both mary kate and ashley have been
pretty focused on becoming fashion
mavens
however throughout the years mary kate
has struck out on her own to debut a
talent that she doesn't seem to share
with her twin
horseback riding according to pop sugar
mary kate was spotted in september of
2016
competing in the annual american gold
cup which is held at the old salem farm
in new york
the publication reported that mary kate
rode three different horses during the
event which is considered one of the
most renowned
show jumping events in the world by that
point mary kate had been riding horses
competitively for three years and had
been photographed riding recreationally
in places like the hamptons
it seems like this hobby holds more
interest for mary kate than acting and
she's clearly talented if she made it
into this famous event
though it might seem like the olsens do
just about everything together you might
not realize that after one twin stopped
acting entirely the other stayed on
screen for just a little while longer
after ashley stopped acting mary kate
continued appearing in projects like the
critically panned
2011 film beastly however in 2012 the
twins told
l uk that they were out of the game for
good as mary kate told the magazine
it just felt right to move away from the
spotlight meanwhile ashley said
i don't have to be a pretty face i've
done that but now it's important and
liberating to be on the other side of
the lens i don't like to be the center
of attention anymore
she added that she's still interested in
hollywood but that if she ever returned
it wouldn't be as an actress the two
clearly found their bliss elsewhere
and with each other mary kate told l
nothing would ever split us up
separate side projects are one thing but
we work better as a team
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one